und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und claus kleber guten
abend der große krach ist ausgefallen in
leipzig beim cdu-parteitag es ist nicht
klar ob der delegierte friedrich merz
ochs aus dem hochsauerlandkreis jemals
vor hatte heute als tiger los zu
springen dass er nicht als sieger
landete das haben dann alle gesehen dass
es im duell zwischen der vorsitzenden
und ihrem vielleicht rivalen noch
prickelnde sekunden gab geschah allein
wegen und total unter kontrolle von
annegret kramp karrenbauer nach angela
merkel offenbar schon die zweite frau an
der cdu-spitze bei der angeblich starke
männer einen großen fehler machen
sie unterschätzen sie aber der reihe
nach erst der bericht von andreas weise
und wulf schmiese fast 90 minuten
spricht die parteichefin
ihre rede solide und dann am ende ein
kuh mit dem hier so niemand gerechnet
hatte wenn ihr der meinung seid dass
dieses deutschland so wie ich es möchte
nicht dass deutschland ist dass ihr euch
vorstellt wenn ihr der meinung seid dass
dieser weg den ich gemeinsam mit euch
gehen möchte nicht der weg ist den ihr
für den richtigen halt da lasst es uns
heute aussprechen und lasst es uns heute
auch beenden hier und jetzt und heute
mucksmäuschenstill im saal wenn ihr die
gleiche lust am gestalten und am
verantworten habt wie ich das habe dann
dann lasst uns hier und jetzt und heute
die ärmel hochkrempeln und anfangen
vielen dank
die 1000 delegierten reagieren mit
minutenlangem donnernden applaus auch
wenn viele von ihm mit dem ersten jahr
der neuen parteivorsitzenden nicht
wirklich glücklich sind
annegret kramp karrenbauer hat einen
kampf gewonnen der gar nicht auf der
tagesordnung stand
und es war eine richtungsweisende rede
dafür danke ich dir herzlich
ein wichtiger punkt ihre rede klare
kante gegen links aber vor allem gegen
die ard das sind die brandstifter und
wir dürfen nie die biedermänner sein die
ihnen auch noch die streichhölzer geben
damit sie diesen kant anstecken können
ansonsten eine deutschland zukunfts rede
eine mit der sie sich quasi schon um die
kanzlerkandidatur bewirkt ich will die
vorsitzende einer partei sein die sich
großartig findet weil sie großartige
politik für heute und für die zukunft
das ist der anspruch den ich an mich
haben dass der anspruch dem sich alle
haare und diesen anspruch müssen wir
gerecht werden
hat man sehr großem applaus die frage
ist immer wie ehrlich so was tatsächlich
ist auf die gesamte masse gesehen oder
ob man da so ein effekt hat dass man
nicht nicht mit klatschen will man merkt
er auch in der parteien unzufriedenheit
auch eine unzufriedenheit mit der großen
koalition
und ich glaube das spürt sie doch also
das spürt sie und einer spürt hier ist
heute nichts für ihn zu holen
friedrich merz will loyal seien vorerst
nicht dieser parteitag wird die
endgültigen entscheidungen treffen
sondern in einem jahr nach einem
weiteren prozess des nachdenkens des
entscheidens des vorbereitend auf diesem
parteitag dann im jahr 2020 der diese
entscheidenden antworten geben muss fast
schon eine randfigur
die kanzlerin von der langjährigen
parteichefin nur ein grußwort
danke an die partei die mich getragen
hat und nicht trägt als bundeskanzlerin
eine abschiedsrede soll das nicht sein
doch manche sehnen sich geradezu nach
dem ende der ära merkel
wir sind sehr dankbar für die guten
jahre unter seiner kanzlerschaft
gleichzeitig spüren wir alle
derzeit findet die zeit für den aufbruch
ist da ich weiß dass du es genau so
sieht unsere partei muss wieder einmal
laufen lernen
ein leipziger lebe wohl ausgerechnet an
dem tag an dem angela merkel genau 14
jahre kanzlerin ist aber es war annegret
kramp karrenbauer parteitag ein deutlich
wulff diese sache mit dem feuert mich
doch wenn es euch nicht passt dieses
manöver zeigte dass stärke weil sie den
parteitag auf ihre
linie brachte oder zeigt dass schwäche
weil sie nach nicht mal einem jahr schon
mit rücktritt drohen musste
zweiteres glaube ich also sie hat den
parteitag gewonnen damit aber dass
pattaya was jetzt kommt hat sie damit
noch lange nicht gewonnen und
wahrscheinlich wird sie auch so einen
move sage ich jetzt mal salopp nicht
wiederholen können also mit dem
rücktritt droht man einmal beim zweiten
mal ist es ein bisschen nach und ich
hatte auch den eindruck dass sie das gar
nicht nötig hatte die rede war okay die
kam ganz gut an
um es im bild zu fassen sie hat er
sozusagen ein tischfeuerwerk gezündet
mit ihrer rede unter applaudierte schon
diese partei und zum schluss hat sie
aber trotzdem noch das große feuerwerk
gezündet mit dieser drohung und das wäre
gar nicht nötig gewesen ist denn jetzt
wenigstens für absehbare zeit für sie
ruhe im karton für absehbare zeit ja
aber märz ihr rivale hat ja im grunde
alles auf wiedervorlage gelegt hat
gesagt er will loyal sein dann hat er
gesagt im grunde kann ich besser reden
als a kk in dem man noch mal an leipzig
2003 seine berühmten bierdeckel rede
erinnerte und das dritte was er gesagt
hat in einem jahr
da entscheiden wir ich bin mir übrigens
nicht sicher ob friedrich merz noch so
der getragene kandidat ist auch hier bei
seinen leuten von nordrhein westfalen
da gab es keine standing ovations also
im grunde ist der kampf nur vertagt wenn
es darum geht wer sollen hinterher
kanzlerkandidatin oder kanzlerkandidat
der cdu werden na gut muss ja auch für
uns wieder spannend werden nächstes jahr
dankeschön und gehen wir von der
politischen ebene auf der
grundsatzentscheidung getroffen werden
runter auf die ebene wo man die folgen
spürt es geht um einen trend der eltern
kranker kinder zur verzweiflung treibt
kinderkliniken schließen in deutschland
weil die politik größere
leistungsfähigere einheiten will die
großen sind natürlich leistungsfähiger
aber oft weiter weg und entfernung ist
das was familien dann als erstes spüren
dort verrichtet
sechs jahre alt ist paul seit fünf
jahren muss er immer wieder in die
kinderklinik sankt augustin die ärzte
hier kennt er gut
paul und seine mutter haben vertrauen in
die spezialisten
doch ihre klinik ist von der schließung
bedroht
das ist schlimm achso für uns persönlich
ist das eine katastrophe
die kinderrheumatologie hier ist für uns
erst mal das nächste erreichbare das
heißt wenn diese klinik schließen würde
müssten wir weiterfahren also ich möchte
mir das nicht vorstellen das wäre ein
erdrutsch die kinderklinik kämpft um
ihre existenz sie hat ihr
kinderherzzentrum geschlossen
denn die uni klinik bonn nur 20
kilometer weiter hat jetzt auch 1 in
sankt augustin machen sie der politik
vorwürfe und typisches problem des
staats versagens wenn ich das mal so
sagen darf das krankenhaus bringt kinder
medizinische leistungen und in der
nachbarschaft im universitätsklinikum
bonn versucht man genau das gleiche zu
tun
ein krankenhaus vor der pleite und die
politik vor der frage wie viele
krankenhäuser braucht das land
die patienten hängen an ihrem
krankenhaus nur wenn jeder alles
anbietet kommt es zu situationen wie
hier in sankt augustin
es ist entstanden weil dieses land keine
krankenhausplanung hört hier in diesem
land macht jedes krankenhaus was ist
wenn politik klinik oder eine andere
klinik
der minister will das ändern mit einer
neuen krankenhausplanung
krankenhausschließungen inklusive denn
alle experten sagen in ganz deutschland
gibt es zu viele krankenhäuser die
anzahl der betten ist so hoch wie
nirgends sonst in europa die zukunft
vieler häuser unsicher die
wirtschaftliche lage der krankenhäuser
hat sich deutlich verschlechtert
einige krankenhäuser melden insolvenz an
es ist schwierig aber noch schwieriger
ist die personelle situation
es wird immer schwieriger für die
krankenhäuser fachpersonal zu finden
zu wenig personal für zu viele häuser
der handlungsdruck ist groß vielleicht
so groß dass der politik gelingt was
bisher
schief ging eine vernünftige
krankenhausplanung mit weniger betten
und mehr qualität was das entscheidende
ist wenn ich nichts machen wie die
strukturveränderung über unser land her
gehen ohne dass sie in ihren eine art
und weise beeinflusst wird
es gibt auch jetzt schon kein monat mehr
wo ich mich in meinen abend nicht mit
einer krankenhaus pleite beschäftige es
geht um die zukunft von kliniken wie in
sankt augustin noch hoffen die familien
der kleinen patienten hier dass ihr haus
erhalten bleibt
professor fred zepp ist der chef der
kinder- und jugendmedizin der uniklinik
mainz das ist eine institution die
sicher nicht geschlossen wird weil sie
einfach zu den großen leistungsfähigen
gehört machen sie sich sorgen über den
trend zum größeren im moment ja man muss
es unterschiedlich betrachten natürlich
haben wir bestimmte speziellen
fragestellungen die wir in zentren
behandeln können aber noch wichtiger und
das ist glaube ich den beitrag
rausgekommen ist natürlich
sicherzustellen dass die versorgung in
der fläche gewährleistet ist und dass
faktisch kinder mit akuten problem
relativ wohnortnah betreut werden können
und da entsteht das problem wie wir
sagen dem fall gesehen haben in bonn und
sankt augustin dass die zunehmende
tendenz kliniken unter wirtschaftlichen
druck und konkurrenz zu stellen dazu
führt das natürlich sagt man versucht
ist sich gegenseitig arbeitsfelder
wegzunehmen und das ist eine große
gefahr wenn es unkontrolliert geschickt
weil wir dann nicht mehr einen bezug zu
den bedürfnissen der menschen im land
haben
gleichzeitig möchte ich natürlich selbst
oder noch mehr für meine kinder
dass die in einem komplizierten fall zu
einem arzt kommen der schon viel
erfahrungen dieser speziellen
möglicherweise gefährlichen geschichte
hat das kriege ich nicht unbedingt den
allernächsten stadt oder kreis
krankenhaus das kann in der tat zu sein
aber dafür müssen ein gestuftes system
haben wir müssen eine grundversorgung
sicherstellen
die gewissermaßen als ein gatekeeper
bereit steht und in der lage ist der das
problem einzuschätzen um den patienten
dann wenn ein zentrum jedenfalls weiter
zu überweisen ja und es sind aber die
kosten auch solcher dezentralen
kleineren kliniken
schießen schnell ins graue und dass
deswegen sagt jetzt die finanzabteilung
des gesundheitsministeriums wir brauchen
effizientere größere betriebe können sie
das auf die dauer von der hand weisen
das ist auch mal wenn man es nur unter
rein wirtschaftlichen aspekt betrachtet
wahrscheinlich richtig aber das ist das
grundproblem der kind über versorgung
von kindern und jugendlichen in
deutschland die versorgung von kindern
und jugendlichen darf nicht ausgelegt
sein gewinne zu machen sondern sie muss
sicher gestellt sie muss gewährleistet
sein und das problem ist dass durch die
einführung der fallpauschalen vor etwa
15 jahren im prinzip die refinanzierung
die finanzierung von kinderkliniken
dauerhaft gestört und unterfinanziert
ist und das führt dazu dass viele kinder
kliniken auch in der fläche gar nicht
mehr extra aus köln finanziert ich meine
krankheit ist eine krankheit das hat
damit zu tun dass das
fallpauschalensystem
versorgungsleistungen begünstigt die
technische leistung entsprechen
operative leistungen röntgenuntersuchung
die sind einfach messbar was macht
kinderheilkunde aus ist es das kind das
zuneigung braucht das vertrauen gewinnen
muss gegenüber dem arzt da braucht man
zeit um sich mit ihm zu beschäftigen das
sind die eltern die man mitnehmen muss
und diese leistung entsprechende medizin
die sind im falschen system überhaupt
nicht dargestellt hätte man das nicht
einfach ein bisschen anpassen dann wäre
es gut mir ja das ist der versuch also
das ist die gesundheitspolitik in berlin
sagt seit 15 jahren wir müssen es nur
schaffen nur besser schaffen dann werden
wir schon haben und ich kann ihnen sagen
der versuch misslingt wir sehen jetzt
schwerwiegende nachteile für die
versorgung von kindern den jugendlichen
in deutschland sowohl in der fläche in
den kommunalen häusern als auch in den
universitären kliniken und wir wissen
zum beispiel die länder wie amerika oder
australien die die fallpauschalen
systeme eigentlich eingeführt haben
haben alle die versorgung von kindern
und jugendlichen wieder aus diesem
system rausgenommen um sicherzustellen
dass eine gute und zuverlässige
gesundheitsversorgung gewährleistet ist
ist das ihre forderung an die politik
sind was brauchen eine forderung
das wäre der intelligenteste weg kinder
und jugendliche heraus aus dem
fallpauschalensystem raus aus dem
wettbewerb mit anderen kliniken in denen
sich petit am ende des tages immer nur
für ihre arbeit rechtfertigen müssen wir
müssen wissen wenn kinder und
jugendmedizin gut funktioniert das was
wir für die gesundheit von
heranwachsenden menschen leisten
das für zu lebensqualität zu längerer
lebenserwartung das garantiert die
zukunft unserer gesellschaft das sind
die menschen die uns des alters tragen
sollen
sie hatten gelegenheit diesen abhält zu
machen danke vielen dank und hier geht
es weiter mit nachrichten von grund-
oder gas gegen das klima paket der
bundesregierung formiert sich weiterer
widerstand
nun will auch schleswig holstein dem
gesetz im bundesrat nicht zustimmen
baden-württemberg hatte zuvor schon
nachbesserungen gefordert
die länder klagen über steuerverluste
für schleswig-holstein beziffert
ministerpräsident günther von der cdu
diese auf 25 millionen euro
in der neuen osnabrücker zeitung fordert
er zudem einen co2 einstiegspreis von 40
euro pro tonne
statt wie geplant zehn euro die
wiederwahl von kevin kühnert als
bundesvorsitzender der jusos dauert an
noch werden die stimmen ausgezählt aber
es ist mit einer bestätigung im amt zu
rechnen
auf dem bundeskongress der jusos in
schwerin hatte er sich ohne
gegenkandidat zur wahl gestellt zuvor
hatte er erneut für ein vorzeitiges ende
der großen koalition geworden
er setze auf einen linksruck und wolle
dass die spd so wörtlich aus der
neoliberalen pampa rauskommen
die rund 300 delegierten ermutigten
ihren vorsitzenden in seinem vorhaben
für einen sitz im neuen spd
bundesvorstand zu kandidieren
in stuttgart haben beschäftigte der auto
und zulieferindustrie gegen die
sparpläne ihrer arbeitgeber protestiert
aufgerufen zu dem aktionstag hatte die
ig metall
die gewerkschaft befürchtet einen
massiven stellenabbau
wegen des wandels zur elektromobilität
und 15.000 arbeitnehmer forderten mehr
mitsprache und sicherheit in diesem
prozess deutschlandweit sind mehr als
800.000 menschen bei autobauern und
zulieferern beschäftigt
der in bremen in abschiebehaft sitzende
libanesische clan-chef miri darf ab
sofort abgeschoben werden
das bremer verwaltungsgericht hat einen
eilantrag von marys anwalt abgelehnt die
richter erklärten der 19 mal in
deutschland rechtskräftig verurteilte
clan-chef stelle eine gefahr für die
allgemeinheit dar
miri war im juli in den libanon
abgeschoben worden und im oktober
illegal wieder nach deutschland
eingereist
die festnahme eines türkischen
vertrauens anwaltes der deutschen
botschaft in ankara wird von koalition
und opposition scharf kritisiert
bundesaußenminister maas will morgen mit
seinem türkischen amtskollegen davutoglu
über den fall und eine schnelle lösung
beraten
am ende des g20 außenministertreffens in
japan dort in hiroshima hatte maß an
zehntausende opfer der
atombombenangriffe von 1945 durch die
usa erinnert ziel müsse bleiben so maaß
irgendwann in einer atomwaffenfreien
welt zu leben
als der amerikanische präsident trump
die lust am kampf gegen den islamischen
staat und gegen syriens machthaber assad
verlor und seine verbündeten in syrien
im stich ließ da standen die kunden
wieder da wie sie in der geschichte
immer wieder da standen nämlich allein
ohne unterstützung und umringt von
gegnern im verbliebenen kurdischen
gebiet im norden von syrien zwischen der
türkisch kontrollierten zone und dem
teil des landes den vorwiegend assad
truppen mit ihren russischen verbündeten
beherrschen
dort traf unsere reporterin katrin
eigendorf auf einheiten kurdischer
frauen die an vorderster front gegen die
terror miliz gekämpft hatten
für die sie ist dieser kampf unter den
neuen umständen schwerer geworden
vorbei ist er nicht
wäre es kein kriegsgebiet dann könnte
diese fahrt in die shopping mall oder in
einen angesagten club führen
wir aber sind unterwegs in nordsyrien
die beiden jungen kundinnen haben sich
entschieden für elan zu kämpfen
wir fahren vorbei an checkpoints unser
ziel ist das trainingslager der
kurdischen frauen miliz in einem
verlassenen bauernhaus bereiten sie sich
auf den krieg vor
nur 35 kilometer von hier liegt die
frontlinie seitdem die türkische armee
die kurdisch verwalteten gebiete aus der
luft bombardiert wisst ihr gegner die
türkei auf die unterstützung amerikas
können sie nicht mehr setzen
die situation ist schwierig für uns wir
sind bereit zu kämpfen und uns zu
verteidigen
wir sind nicht abhängig von amerika oder
anderen kräften
wir sind nur abhängig von uns allen judy
ist mit 21 jahren schon eine der
erfahrenen hier
sie ist die ausbilderin ruhig und
besonnen erklärt sie auch hier ist die
enttäuschung anzumerken dass amerika den
kurden die unterstützung entzieht ist
für sie verrat doch sie haben eine klare
strategie die türkischen kräfte kämpfen
seite an seite mit den e s kämpfern
wir kämpfen um unsere menschen und
städte von ihnen zu befreien
uns interessieren russische und regime
kräfte nicht die front ist hier in der
nähe
es gibt heftige zusammenstöße zwischen
denen und uns mal übernehmen sie dörfer
dann holen wir sie zurück ein video das
sie selbst aufgenommen haben
es zeigt die einheit an der front im
januar männer und frauen die
gleichberechtigt kämpfen so der
grundsatz der kurdischen volkes
verteidigungs milizen in syrien
ihr größter erfolg ist ihr sieg gegen
den islamischen staat
11.000 männer und frauen sind dabei
gestorben die kurden haben im kampf
gegen den esm großes opfer gebracht und
fühlen sich jetzt von den usa im stich
gelassen
sie schreckt das nicht sie wollen
trotzdem kämpfen denn nicht unweit von
hier rücken türkische truppen und die
von ihnen unterstützten radikalen
milizen auf kurdische dörfer vor
selbstverständlich hantieren sie mit
waffen dass ihre gegner nicht an
gleichberechtigung glauben daran liegt
für sie ihre besondere schlagkraft
wenn unsere feinde uns sehen sieht man
in ihren augen dass sie große angst
haben islamische kämpfer möchten nicht
von frauen umgebracht werden dann kommen
sie nicht in den himmel
sie glauben nicht dass frauen kämpfen
können und bereit sind zu töten
es geht zurück an einen anderen
übungsplatz wie immer sind sie unterwegs
im pickup die jüngsten unter ihnen sind
gerade erst 18 jahre alt doch ihre
zukunft sehen sie alle erst einmal an
der frontlinie eines krieges dessen ende
sobald nicht absehbar ist
geplant war das nicht aber es hat auch
niemand was dagegen das ist zu einer
sendung über starke frauen geraten
die finanzwelt schaut heute auf den
ersten großen auftritt der neuen
präsidentin der europäischen zentralbank
christine lagarde an der sehr lockeren
geldpolitik wolle sie festhalten
erklärte sie auf einem bankenkongress
frank bethmann und dabei aber die
nebeneffekte besser im auge behalten was
hören die experten heraus naja lagarde
sucht nach wegen wie sie auch die banken
wieder in ihre seite bekommt ein
zentrales problem denn seitdem die ezb
diesen extremen niedrigzins kurs fährt
verdienen die kreditinstitute zusehends
weniger geld offen griffen führende
banker die ezb zuletzt an sie vor allem
würden die rechnung bezahlen
so gesehen war dass viele gar tiere
frankfurt heute beim bankenkongress
nicht einfach zunächst warb sie für mehr
unterstützung bei der dis klären
es ist klar dass die geldpolitik ihr
ziel sehr viel schneller erreichen
könnte mit sehr viel weniger
nebenwirkungen wenn andere politische
maßnahmen das wachstum auch mit stützen
würden magaths appell an die euro länder
ihr müsst mehr investieren auch
vorgänger draghi hatte das immer wieder
gefordert lagarde verknüpfte ist heute
aber mit einem wir-gefühl europa als
ganzes müsse seine potenziale besser
nutzen
dazu wird auch dass die banken gestärkt
werden müssen zentraler baustein eine
banken
dafür notwendig einheitliche finanz
regeln für alle banken in europa
richtlinien zur banken abwicklung und
damit verbunden eine gemeinsame
einlagensicherung hätten wir eine bank
union sagte finanzminister olaf scholz
dazu heute hätten wir mehr wachstum
hätten wir mehr arbeitsplätze und wäre
europa insgesamt stabiler
das sind ganz neue töne die christine
lagarde heute aber sicher gerne gehört
haben wird vielen dank
zu wenig bewegung zu viel trägheit das
beklagt die weltgesundheitsorganisation
whu in ihrer neuen weltweiten studie
über jugendliche sie rät mindestens eine
stunde pro tag körperlich aktiv zu sein
der studie nach schaffen dass rund 81
prozent der elf- bis 17-jährigen nicht
bei den mädchen sind es hierzulande
sogar 88 prozent
die experten warnen langfristig könnte
der bewegungsmangel zu herz kreislauf
erkrankungen diabetes und demenz führen
eine meldung vom sport deutschlands
tennis herren müssen weiter auf den
ersten einzug in ein davis cup
halbfinale seit zwölf jahren warten
das deutsche team ist gegen
großbritannien ausgeschieden philipp
kohlschreiber und jan lennard struff
verloren jeweils ihre einzige das doppel
ist damit bedeutungslos
das sandmännchen wird heute 60 jahre alt
seinen ersten auftritt hatte der kleine
mann mit der zipfelmütze dem spitzbart
und vor allem seiner legendären gut
nacht melodie im ddr fernsehen
in der ard gegen das sandmännchen erst
neun tage später auf sendung und auch
mit 60 denkt nicht ans aufhören
es gibt neue folgen unter anderem auf
kika immer um 18 uhr 50 oder rund um die
uhr im netz auf kika de die verheerenden
waldbrände in australien sind ein
bisschen aus dem fokus der nachrichten
geraten weil es scheinbar nichts neues
zu berichten gibt die katastrophe
schreitet einfach voran
in wenigen tagen sind über eine million
hektar wald verbrannt mehr als in den
letzten drei jahren zusammen genommen
die menschen haben das klima und die
landschaft verändert die folgen in der
natur sind jetzt stärker als die
sogenannte zivilisation und am
schlimmsten betroffen ist die provinz
new south wales
die folgen reichen bis in die metropole
sydney das ausmaß übersteigt das
vorstellungsvermögen in solchen
situationen das ist oft so dass ein
detail ein opfer in den mittelpunkt
rückt zudem jeder mensch eine beziehung
hat ist nicht so wichtig an sich aber es
hilft zu verstehen unsere südostasien
korrespondent normen odenthal hat so
eine geschichte mitgebracht sind nie im
trüben sidney im rauch australiens
größte metropole sonst eine perle liegt
unter dicken qualm bürger klagen über
atemnot die behörden warnen vor
gesundheitsgefahren das könne noch tage
so weitergehen denn der wind steht
schlecht mehr als 100 feuer lodern ihr
im osten des landes einige davon außer
kontrolle
höchste gefahr das bild vom koala louis
geht um die welt sein eukalyptus wald
wurde zur hölle
lewis wird gerettet er hat es gepackt er
lebt wird gepflegt in kuala krankenhaus
viele koalas haben grausame verletzungen
viele die sie jetzt zu uns bringen
können wir nur noch einschläfern
wir können sie nicht retten und das ist
tragisch die koalas hier sind sozusagen
der absolute kernbestand genetisch
vielfältig sie haben eine nationale
bedeutung in kuala hospital von port
macquarie kämpfen sie um jedes einzelne
leben immer auch wenn es nicht brennt
den tieren geht es nicht gut sie leiden
unter den menschengemachten klimawandel
unter der extremen dürre die nun auch
die feuer anheizt
immer mehr werden gefunden halb
verdurstet schwer krank jeder patient
bekommt eine marke und einem mikrochip
man sieht sich meistens zweimal im leben
und dann kann jede information wichtig
sein für die ärzte sich mal wenn sie
gesund sind riechen sie gut nach
eukalyptus wenn sie krank sind stinken
sie zu essen ist eine von dutzenden
freiwilligen die sich dem wohl der
koalas verschrieben haben die
vergangenen tage jedoch haben aufs gemüt
geschlagen das leiden der tiere in den
brennenden wäldern hat eine menge
hoffnung gekostet der bestand geht stark
zurück ich glaube wir verlieren diesen
kampf sie bekommen so wenig nachwuchs
und sie sterben und zweck in großer zahl
ich fürchte wir haben den kampf sogar
schon verloren die feuer wüten weiter
gnadenlos fressen sich durchs land
rauben hab und gut machen menschen
obdachlos
aber wie sehr sie australien einen
ganzen kontinent ins mark treffen das
wird vielleicht kaum deutlicher als am
schicksal der koalas dazu noch eine
politische randnotiz im mai ist in
australien eine regierung wiedergewählt
worden die den konsens der wissenschaft
über den menschengemachten klimawandel
für unsinn hält und gerade das größte
kohle gebiet des landes zum abbau
freigegeben hat
krasse nachrichten anderer art gleich in
der heute-show krass lustig hoffentlich
und wir wünschen ein schönes wochenende
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren heute
nacht ist es in süddeutschland kalt
genug für glätte
im norden gibt es dichte wolken und das
bleibt auch morgen über tags über die
alpen bläst erfüllen er bringt sehr viel
sonnenschein mit und bringt temperaturen
von 13 bis 16 grad an den alpen sonst
werden 7 bis 12 grad erreicht 7 bis 14
grad gibt es dann am sonntag dazu
sonnenschein nebel oder wolken bei uns
also ruhiges spätherbst wetter ganz
anders auf der alpensüdseite da regnet
und schneit es morgen fast
ununterbrochen
es können 300 liter regen pro
quadratmeter zusammenkommen und in den
westalpen oberhalb von 1600 meter 130 cm
schnee große neuschneemengen können
lawinen auslösen
entscheidend ist der aufbau der
schneedecke sie besteht aus
verschiedenen schichten ganz oben liegt
der neuschnee seine fein verästelten
schneekristalle verhaken sich ineinander
wird der schnee älter lösen sich diese
häkchen die kristalle stumpfen ab
sie sind die grundlage für den besonders
gefährlichen schwimm schnee wenn es taut
wachsen die als schneekristalle zu
pyramiden und verlieren den kontakt
untereinander
manchmal findet sich in so einem schnee
profil auch eine harte schicht wenn die
schneeoberfläche in der sonne auftaut
und dieses wasser auf dem schnee nachts
wieder festfriert und den harsch bildet
oberhalb dessen sicher wie löst
hoffentlich nicht schönen abend noch